christmas christmas christmas
christmas holiday i've got it i can give
you that perfect christmas you've never
had
jinx and i have been working together
for a decade now since before
either of us was on drag race and we
have
had those crazy experiences going from
you know soft
shoeing uh on a pool table for
pennies uh to traveling touring the
world
and you know dealing with and getting to
have all these amazing fans and dealing
with the
criticism and and uh and through all of
that
our friendship and relationship has only
gotten stronger what is the jinx and de
la holiday special gonna be
all about what will people see when they
tune in so rather than
doing um just a recorded version of one
of our live shows
um which was our first idea you know it
was like really
let's do this real simple and just um
put on a really good recording of our
live show and then about a week later
dayla calls me and says
wanna just write a whole new movie
instead so that's what we did
all of this crazy it's supposed to get
me in the holiday spirit
you know like if we're gonna write a
movie it's gonna be the best damn movie
either of us can
write together so i think people are
going to really enjoy it if you've seen
our stage shows i think it has
all um of the best qualities of those
you get to really um
see our our little laurel and hearty red
and stimpy laverne and shirley dynamic
play out but
you know we get to um do all of the
songs and the comedy that you would
catch on stage but we also
have i think written a really um fun and
funny
story that is also has a heartfelt
message about togetherness at this time
the amount of passion and the amount of
dedication that we poured into this film
really did feed my artistic soul in a
way that i hadn't realized i was missing
so much
along with the film you're going to be
releasing an album
of some of the incredible music in it
with soon to be classics like
a gay and a stranger
don't waste time with head if
a red head bear backs you you've been
gingerbread do you think this film will
kind of
help bring the power of the queers
back to christmas that's really i think
the mission statement
of our film you know christmas is this
inescapable thing that happens
to us and there's so many expectations
there's uh so many kind of uh images out
there of family and homecoming that
you're comparing yourself
to you can invent your own traditions
and you can create your own
family you are just spreading holiday
cheer everywhere you are
part of the first studio-backed
gate rom-com happiest season being part
of that film
with such an incredible cast what was
that like for both of you
it was incredible it was incredible um
you've all been a really wonderful
friend to both of us for years now
every actor we interacted with um
on set was kind and gracious and and
just
it was one of those just like dream
experiences we were respected as
actors we weren't treated like drag
queen novelty acts
which happened a lot in hollywood you
know we were treated
as as as bona fide actors
on a bonafide movie set i've been
screaming into the void for ages now
that um we need more and more
um queer programming for queer people by
queer people
and it's so you know it's so refreshing
to see a film like this
um you know so much queer content is
kind of tinged in tragedy
you know um and this is just a film
that is joya joyous it's inviting
i mean it's really just us being invited
to the party in a way that's been
overwhelmingly lacking in the past
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos